man welcome man happy to be back man
yeah last time you came it was with Adam
yeah put you back here by yourself yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well first of
all man I'm super proud of you bro I'm
super proud of you this guy I remember
this guy uh every night of the week
would be at a nightclub somewhere in the
country yep
somehow I was like I was just always so
impressed at your ability to be
everywhere
you were like outside outside I put more
time into going out than putting in work
than your music career for sure
everything yo do you think everything do
you think you catching that record juice
like was a gift and a curse because you
caught one and then it was like over
because you were just like everywhere I
wouldn't say it's a gift and a curse I
just feel like I got super lucky and I
didn't know what to do after that so I
was like [ __ ] it let the good times roll
dude that record was so hard and then
you you cut bro you cut like the hardest
dub plates for DJs a million of them
boots like Kev got the juice but that's
shout out to uh DJ head because he's the
one who told me to give him a custom one
then I was like oh I'm gonna make one
for everybody if I play that [ __ ]
everywhere yeah because I was like it
says my name in it bro and it was like
such a perfect like
that's that's like a la staple record a
definitely you got a few I got a few I
got some more coming I ain't done well
listen you obviously a lot of people
more recently know you as a personality
for sure but you are a veteran La rapper
and I've been [ __ ] with you and
supporting you for
it's been a long time probably eight or
nine years oh yeah getting close to a
decade yeah yeah
um but just to see you kind of like
because you've always had a great
personality
I think you came on our show freestyle
once and brought a wig I did I pulled
the wick out and that was actually my
baby Mama's wig yeah you pull the [ __ ]
it off you pulled the weave out bro yeah
man but you've always had like this
personality so it's just dope to see you
kind of like Embrace that [ __ ] you know
what I mean because I feel like there's
like
did you feel like you were fighting any
sort of stigma or hesitation to like
dive all the way in with that because oh
hell yeah I mean look the thing is is
like
when you people put their own
insecurities on you and stuff like that
you know what I'm saying they put their
own projections on you and
um I just I'm just happy that I've
always been the person that listened to
myself so even when I said I wanted to
be a rapper you know my family at the
time they were like okay I'm not mad at
them for that but they couldn't see it
right you know I mean like they it
didn't make sense to them was like wait
a minute he's just gonna you're gonna
rap and you're gonna make it you're
gonna do this you're gonna do that so
it's just like [ __ ] I was living at my
granny house I was 25 26 right so you
know your family looking at you like man
man listen you grown get a job right you
feel me I got my baby mama living there
my daughter right under we Under One
Roof and I'm just sitting there telling
them just having that self-belief and
having that faith that something's gonna
work and then something did work and you
know that pivot me you know doing music
and you know while that was going on you
know I feel like I got I kind of got to
a a ceiling where it was just like damn
the [ __ ] ain't getting no bigger and I'm
watching this [ __ ] decline but still
Keeping the Faith because you know I'm
like something is gonna pop up up and
then the no jumper [ __ ] happened
randomly right you ended an interview
right and then it went well bro almost
everything in my life
that's been very successful for me like
it randomly happened and I know it's not
random you feel me that's all God but it
just randomly happened like a lot of
[ __ ] I didn't plan for yeah because uh
for you because like were there people
your music industry friends that were
like yo man once you kind of go that
direction
there's no coming back everybody
told me it's a bad decision you need to
focus more on your music you need to do
this you need to do this you do that and
I'm just like okay and I'm gonna keep it
real with you when Adam first approached
me he was you know I was supposed to
just do the Snapchat show I wasn't even
I wasn't even supposed to be full time
right I was just gonna do it
covet happened once it happened
they was like do you want to keep doing
it so I thought I was going to be able
to stay under the radar during the
Snapchat show because I'm like no one's
[ __ ] on Snapchat I'm like I don't
know yeah nobody in this industry that
was actively on Snapchat at the time so
I'm like okay I can skate under the rug
with this with the Snapchat [ __ ] and
then you know still do my music don't
nobody know and then I just started from
the Snapchat show I just started seeing
people just recognize me and they would
come up to me like I like watching you
on Snapchat like younger kids and [ __ ]
and I'm like what the [ __ ] right and
these all different raised people and
I'm like wait a minute this is you know
different yeah and they just coming up
to me coming up to me and then I started
subbing on the no jumper show and just
the the amount of people that was just
[ __ ] with me I was like damn like
this [ __ ] is dope it's a little
different yeah and then you know that
turned into what it turned into but I
mean now everybody says oh you're a
genius for what you did I'm like [ __ ]
you the same [ __ ] who told me right
don't do that that was a dumb decision
you know I mean now I see everybody now
everyone in there bro let me tell you
something bro it's so funny because even
now like I have people who are like
people you wouldn't expect to want to
start their own podcast trust me right
and they call me and they're like hey
man look I'm trying to do a podcast I'm
like you're trying to do a punk